bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission
reportage climat économies d'énergie
l'heure des choix pour l'europe
la commission a fixé ses objectifs d'ici
à 2030 en matière de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique parce que ça
chauffe un but réduire de 40% les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
protéger l'environnement et stimuler la
compétitivité des entreprises
un objectif pas assez ambitieux dit on
du côté du parlement européen des
propositions qui seront discutés lors
d'un sommet européen les 20 et 21 mars
reportage en france nous allons voir
comment l'hexagone veut se poser en
exemple en la matière c'est le système
des certificats d'énergie les
entreprises sont sommés de trouver des
moyens pour réussir à faire ces fameuses
économies d'énergie mais l'actualité
assez l'ukraine face au rouleau
compresseur us
que peut faire l'europe elle a une arme
les sanctions économiques c'est notre
sujet d'actu du jour avant de retrouver
guy verhofstadt l'ancien premier
ministre de belgique candidat à la
présidence de la commission européenne
revient d'un voyage en ukraine c'est
l'occasion de discuter de voir son
regard sur la crise que subit le pays
le gaz russe moyen de pression de moscou
pour empêcher les européens à intervenir
sur la crise craignait pas si simple que
cela
une grande partie du gaz consommé par
les français les allemands les italiens
vient de russie
les plus dépendants sont les pays de
l'est à court terme les européens
seraient très gêné de ne plus être
desservir au gaz par la russie mais à
long terme la russie ne peut pas se
permettre de ne plus vendre août il ne
tiendra pas s'il n'a pas de rentrées
fiscales
en fait la russie a plus besoin de
vendre aux européens que n'ont besoin
d'acheter face à la force militaire
russe
la force de frappe de l'europe est
économie avec des sanctions
la russie est le troisième partenaire
économique de l'europe
il ya donc toute une série d'accords
entre moscou et bruxelles
et ce sont ces accords là qui sont
menacés ensuite ce sont des visas aussi
qu'ils pourraient ne plus être accordé
dans certains cas aux citoyens russes
des sanctions qui pourraient toucher
personnellement vladmir poutine et ses
proches
par exemple le gel de leurs avoirs ce
qui serait une grande une humiliation
qui pourrait le faire tomber de son
cheval cet arsenal de sanctions
pourraient être utilisés par l'europe
sauf si la russie accepte de retirer
très vite toutes ses troupes d'ukraine
autant dire qu'à bruxelles
personne n'y croit plus
alors il s'est rendu en ukraine au plus
fort de la crise il ya deux semaines
juste après les choses ont évolué très
vite avec le départ de ianoukovitch
la nomination d'un gouvernement de
transition et l'arrivée des troupes
russes en crimée avec nous l'ancien
premier ministre de belgique et chef de
file des libéraux au parlement repère
également aux candidats à la présidence
de la commission européenne guy
verhofstadt bonjour première question
toute simple est ce que l'europe elle
peut brandir cette arme économique face
à la russie je pense que oui je pense
que oui parce que il n'ya que même
beaucoup de russes beaucoup d'oligarques
y ont leurs savoirs leurs comptes
bancaires en europe qui ont des fortunes
qui ont été investis en europe
et là je crois qu'il faut vraiment être
il faut frapper très fort parce que
c'est quand même inacceptable que la
fédération russe a simplement et
simplement rentrer dans le territoire au
cren est selon moi la stratégie de
poutine est très simple la stratégie des
poutines chaque fois la même chose c'est
comme on a vu en géorgie en 2008 s'est
il entre dans un pays qui n'est plus un
pays ami et puis ils essayent de créer
je dire un conflit gellé un confit gérer
c'est à dire il ya des troupes russes
qui reste là territoire et puis il ya
tout un dialogue politique qui
s'installe et et qui va durer des années
et des années comme ça on voit autour de
la russie un grand nombre de conflits
gelés maintenant dans la crimée mais il
existe déjà sur la frontière entre
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie karabakh
nagorno karabagh il existe au nord de la
georgie dont la city du sud un problème
un conflit gelé la même chose en
moldavie avec la transnistrie donc comme
ça c'est la crimée va s'ajouter à la
longue rue j'ai réfléchi selon une
stratégie réfléchie tout à fait tout à
fait donc ou aux biens on est ami avec
monsieur poutine alors tout va bien ou
bien on n'est pas amis on est un ennemi
alors il va installer dans les
frontières de ce pays un conflit un
conflit qui après un certain temps sera
gelé
donc l'europe c'est des sanctions
économiques à ce n'est pas sympa on va
pas envoyer des troupes non
ça ne veut mourir pour sébastopol
neurones a quand même vu que par exemple
dans le cas des anneaux corric ça m'a
servi à quelque chose les sanctions
c'est quoi ces sanctions économiques
prises sanctions économiques c'est
d'abord naturellement tous les accords
au niveau commercial qu'on a avec la
russie et là on peut freiner on peut
dire on va gérer certaines de ces
accords ou peut-être aussi essayer de
diminuer l'importation d'énergie de
produits énergétiques qui vient de la
russie
et comme il y a pas gêné les européens
sagna gaz russe commet une énorme offre
sur le marché mondial par exemple les
américains qui étaient normalement un
importateur de produits énergétiques
sont devenus un exportateur de produits
énergétiques et donc il ya une énorme
donc plus dépendre de la russie alors et
quoi plus dépenses je ne dirais pas
diversifié vraiment en tout cas
diversifier davantage c'est ça aussi le
but de la politique énergétique on doit
développer au niveau de l'union
européenne a dit vous étiez place menden
à kiev il ya deux semaines quel peuple
vous avez rencontré
moi j'ai rencontré des simples citoyens
sur la place de my dad
des simples citoyens qui veulent vivre
dans un état dans une pays tout à fait
normal parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
pays l'ukraine qui est tout à fait
corrompus dans tous ces secteurs dans
toutes ses activités
par exemple si vous voulez entrer comme
jeunes dans la politique buy la partie
politique va vous désignez un oligarque
cet oligarque va payer votre campagne
électorale et vous allez dépendre de cet
oligarque pendant des années pendant des
décennies pendant toute votre monde où
la même chose un hôpital normalement
c'est gratuit mais les gens doivent
payer au dessous de la table des zones
horaires aux médecins aux par exemple la
justice la justice est complètement
corrompu aussi on peut acheter des ddv
redick je dirais et des décisions du du
tribunal donc c'était les gens demandent
c'est vraiment de vivre dans un pays
normal qui n'est pas corrompue la fin de
la corruption
la démocratie aussi et c'est ces gens
que j'ai rencontrés sur la place mallet
sont pas tous pro européen
pour eux je dois dire beaucoup de gens
que j'ai rencontrés ils disent n'importe
qui c'est la fédération russe qui
s'occupe de nous oula l'union européenne
ce qui est important c'est qu'on vit
dans un état démocratique sans
corruption et naturellement ils ne
regardent pas ce qu'ils savent très bien
qu'ils essaient pas poutine qui va leur
garantir je dirais un état démocratique
puisqu'il n'est pas démocrate au sens
propre pire la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est est-ce que l'ukraine va
s'arrimer à l'europe
regardez ce qu'en pense votre collègue
daniel cohn-bendit on l'écouté vous
réagissez juste après
l'europe doit essayer de donner une
perspective aussi à l'ukraine ne pas
dire n'importe quoi que demain ça sera
l'adhésion non y aura l'adhésion de
l'ukraine en europe cantonnera les états
unis l'europe
donc c'est pas pour demain
voilà j'attends d'autres groupes faut
arrêter de donner des rêves aux
ukrainiennes et de leur dire qu'ils vont
qui vont adhérer à l'europe alors que
personne personne n'en veut pour
l'instant c'est pas la question pour le
moment je pense pas qu'on peut dire a
dont 50 disent on va pouvoir faire
entrer l'ukraine dans l'union européenne
il faut pas faire cette erreur là ce
qu'il faut leur ce qu'il faut faire
c'est vraiment tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour que il s'installe une
démocratie stable et qui est
naturellement qui se base sur les
valeurs européennes
et là on peut aider de différentes
manières tout d'abord en faisant que
c'est sont ces élections du 25 mai
prochain ce sont des élections sérieuse
ce qui n'a jamais été les cachets des
élections en europe aussi sa bouche de
ses symboles c'est à ça parce que c'est
quand même ça qu'il faut une fois
souligné au moment où il ya des gens qui
meurent dans les rues de kiev pour les
valeurs et de l'union européenne
à l'intérieur de l'union européenne il
ya les eurosceptiques qui sont en train
de critiquer et l'union européenne
et est ce qu'on peut faire et on doit
faire des choses pour lui car c'est
d'abord à aider à organiser ces
élections et donc il faut envoyer des
les observateurs mais des observateurs
maintenant parce que si on veut
falsifier les élections on ne fait pas
deux jours avant les élections c'est
maintenant que ça se passe et et
deuxièmement il faut donner ou si on
aide financière on ne peut pas le faire
tout seul avec l'union européenne il
faut le faire avec le fonds monétaire
international et je crois que la
première chose à faire c'est très vite
dans les heurts dans les jours qui
viennent ouvrir une aide financière et
surtout je crois que le crâne a besoin
tout de suite d'environ 2 milliards
d'euros pour couvrir les besoins urgents
gloriana qui n'est pas d'accord avec
vous ainsi vladimir poutine
il ne lâche pas la faire il a parlé le
président russe a donc dénoncé un coup
d'état anticonstitutionnelle une prise
de pouvoir par les armes en ukraine
à la question d'un journaliste qui lui
demandait qui était responsable de ce
coup d'état
le président russe a par les deux
groupes de combat et a évoqué la
présence de formateurs occidentaux c'est
vous les formateurs occidentaux les
députés roméo m'a pas du tout tout ça
c'est une
c'est une vision complètement erroné
d'être dans la réalité si monsieur
poutine
c'est quoi une vision mais si vous
deviez aller une fois au à la place
maïdan il y a quelques jours où il ya
quelques semaines il y aura vu tout un
peuple qui aspire en fait la démocratie
est un pays qui n'est pas corrompue et
c'est pas seulement dans l'ouest du pays
c'est aussi dans l'est du pays parce que
ce n'est pas parce que les gens parlent
à la langue russe est qu'ils sont moins
ukrainien mais j'écoutais il pense que
quelqu'un qui parle russe est
automatiquement un russe à ce n'est pas
le cas il ya beaucoup d'européens qui
parle russe et on a aussi une obligation
envers il faut les protéger ses
minorités russes et qui habitent dans
les états bâle par exemple qui habite
naturellement en outre m merci guy
verhofstadt d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et maintenant place aux
reportages on va parler économie
d'énergie en europe d'or quelques jours
à semer des chefs d'état européens va
discuter du paquet énergie climat
proposé par la commission le parlement
européen lui avait adopté une directive
européenne sur l'efficacité énergétique
à chaque état membre doit présenter un
plan pour répondre à son obligation
d'économiser l'énergie avec le système
des certificats d'énergie la france se
pose en exemple c'est un reportage de
caroline motte
régulièrement stéphane fait du
covoiturage
une pratique en vogue depuis 5 ans la
vente âge pour lui voyager moins cher
tout en consommant moins de carburant
récemment j'ai eu l'occasion en faisant
un voyage
entre rennes et paris de me retrouver
dans une voiture ville et je me suis dit
ben tiens pourquoi pas moi pour une fois
plutôt que d'être passager pourquoi pas
être conducteur
aujourd'hui il se rend à lille pour le
week end bonjour cyril c'est ça stéphane
enchanté il a rendez vous avec cyril à
la porte de bagnolet ski m'arrangerait
après tout je peux faire évidemment un
petit détour mais ça serait de s'arrêter
au niveau de la gare lille flandres
direction la pompe à essence en tant que
conducteur stéphane a reçu une carte
carburant soit 20 euros d'essence
gratuite à dépenser dans les stations
total donc notre saison est de 60
alors je vous paye une partie avec ça un
bon plan qui trouve son origine dans les
certificats d'économie d'énergie
un dispositif qui oblige tous les
distributeurs de carburant à prouver
leur engagement pour l'environnement en
tant qu entreprise pétrolière total a
conclu un accord avec blabla car le
leader européen du covoiturage s'est
agit donc comme une carotte une
motivation pour les automobilistes
français à se mettre au covoiturage pour
tester et obtenir ce chèque carburant
qui est une forme de motivation
chaque pays a son propre système de
certificats d'économie d'énergie
en france le dispositif a vu le jour en
2006 avec l'adoption de la loi pope qui
fixe les orientations de la politique
énergétique depuis fin 2012
l'europe encadre les programmes de
chaque état membre avec un objectif
réduire la consommation d'énergie de 1,5
pour cent par an depuis le 5 décembre
tous les pays de l'union doivent
présenter un plan d'action
chaque état devra rendre compte chaque
année à la commission de la manière dont
ils réussissent à suivre leur plan
d'action chiffré à leur plan de marche
pour justement atteindre ses 1,5 %
d'économie d'énergie de consommation
annuelle en france les fournisseurs
d'énergie et de carburants sont des
obligé s'il ne respecte pas les
obligations
ils sont pénalisés financièrement donc
on parle d'eux
de plus d'un milliard et demi par
exemple si on prend juste l'obligation
de leclerc et donc on doit être amené à
plus de 3 milliards potentiels à
l'échelle de total donc ce sont des
pénalités qu'ils trouvent ça sent sont
inimaginables une pénalité qui agit
comme une pression pour les fournisseurs
de carburant total auchan carrefour
leclerc
ils sont tous concernés notre obligation
est tellement importante que nous avions
calculé qu'il faudrait par exemple
fermer tous nos magasins pendant un an
et ne plus consommer d'énergie pour
pouvoir respecter cette obligation
donc nous avons été chercher ailleurs
nous aidons donc les particuliers mais
nous avons aussi des êtres d'autres
entreprises qui font des économies en
subventionnant des travaux exemple à
breuillet dans une commune de la
banlieue parisienne
sarah a refait toute sa maison soucieuse
de réduire sa facture d'énergie
elle a voulu changer sa chaudière
convaincu par les publicités sur les
primes énergie elle a rempli son dossier
sur le site internet d'une grande
surface
voilà la chaudière qu'on installé en
novembre 2013
donc c'est une chaudière à condensation
très simple d'utilisation j'ai envoyé
l'attestation de fin de travaux la
facture avec mon dossier rempli à auch
en voilà et par la suite ils m'ont
crédité 504 euros sur ma carte de
fidélité grâce à ce système incitatif
les entreprises peuvent tenir leurs
promesses pour le bénéficiaire ce bon
d'achat est valable dans tout le magasin
c'est un partenariat gagnant gagnant là
avec ma prime de 580 je fais mes courses
au gratuitement pendant un mois le
dispositif made in france des
certificats d'économies d'énergie est un
succès à tel point que la commission
européenne a invité chaque état membre à
le prendre pour modèle c'est une vraie
révolution parce que derrière ça en
découle par exemple en france
l'intensification des certificats et qui
dit intensification du dispositif des
certificats dits effectivement tout une
modification de tout ce qui est lié aux
économies énergies entre les fabricants
les installateurs les fournisseurs
d'énergie des nouvelles offres des
nouveaux produits donc ça a un impact
très concret dans la vie quotidienne de
tout à chacun
pour les ménages cette politique
volontariste se traduit par une
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat pour la
france l'enjeu est de taille
améliorer sa compétitivité quant à
l'europe elle s'engage définitivement
sur la voie de l'efficacité énergétique
voilà c'était un reportage de caroline
motte avec nous deux spécialistes sophie
auconie bonjour vous êtes eurodéputés
udi membre du ppe à vos côtés michèle
rivasi bonjour vous êtes eurodéputée
europe ecologie les verts leur première
question tout ça vous venez de voir le
reportage de caroline motte
ce certificat d'économie d'énergie
apparemment une contente tout le monde
oui il est il est satisfaisant dans sa
mise en oeuvre et les satisfaisant dans
l'apport qu'il représente d'un point de
vue de l'environnement d'écologie mais
aussi d'un point de vue de soutien aux
citoyens et de l'europe concrète auprès
des citoyens
le seul souci pour moi et je pense que
ça c'est très franco français c'est son
manque de lisibilité son manque de
visibilité et je regrette qu' il n'y ait
pas eu une véritable campagne de
communication pour que les choses soient
clairement exprimé aux citoyens à la
fois dans l'effort que font les
entreprises pour aller dans le sens de
l'économie d'énergie et de soutien et
d'accompagnement citoyens mais aussi de
l'europe qui participent à améliorer le
quotidien de des français et des
françaises est bien entendu de
l'ensemble des citoyens européens en cas
de manque de lisibilité michèle rivasi
euh oui mais je pense qu'on fait pas
assez la publicité là dessus mais c'est
vraiment ce système
voyez c'est l'écologie positive un sou
vandier l'écologie punitive mais elle
est positive serait elle profite au
pouvoir d'achat des gens là on l'a très
bien vu que ce soit sur le covoiturage
que ce soit sur les économies d'énergie
sur le chauffage et en même temps elle
rencontre des directions de l'europe où
il faut réduire notre consommation
d'énergie passe assez c'est vraiment le
négawatt qu'il faut faire et puis en
même temps il faut être beaucoup plus
indépendant vis-à-vis des énergies
fossiles et on voit bien ce qui se passe
en ukraine à l'heure actuelle regardé
comme on est dépendants du gaz russe
et c'est pour cent que si il faut
absolument suivre les écologistes pour
que l'on soit de plus en plus
indépendants sur nos ressources
énergétiques
sinon la guerre en ce moment qui est en
train de se forme en t eh bien on va pas
pouvoir être indépendant des russes
vis-à-vis du gaz sont les dépendants
le 1/4 de la provision de gaz provient
de la russie et 60% du gaz passe par
l'ukraine
donc vous voyez bien que lorsqu'on parle
d'autonomie lorsqu'on parle
d'indépendance
lorsqu'on parle aussi de diminuer sous
les déficits commerciaux liés aux
énergies fossiles c'est vraiment une
urgence et ses certificats contribuer si
vous voulez à cette réduction et à ce
changement de comportement
il ya un sujet un souci qui n'a pas été
évoquée dans dans le sujet c'est la
pénalité financière a pour les plus gros
pollueurs ya rien à rien de contraignant
des entreprises nous disent nous les
pénalités financières sont tellement
grosse tellement grande qu'on va jamais
les payer donc ça sert à rien mais je
pense que c'est un véritable moyen de
pression qui permet à ces entreprises
qui incite ces entreprises à aller dans
le sens de ce qu'ils ont mis en oeuvre
alors certes effectivement ces
contraintes sont très élevés et
paraissent difficiles à mettre en oeuvre
mais pour autant elles sont un moyen de
pression qui pousse ces entreprises
allaient dans le sens de
l'accompagnement et c'est de ça dont a
besoin le citoyen européen en général
c'est d'être accompagné par ses grandes
entreprises qui participent à l'énergie
dans l'europe pour améliorer leur quête
quotidien pour éviter la rupture
la fracture énergétique et aussi pour
lutter contre eux rien de contraignant
les lobbies sont activés les jeunes
recrutés les lobbys c'était le
gaspillage plus totale on était en
surconsommation que ça soit des voitures
qui consomment énormément des chaudières
et consomme énormément
maintenant on leur met la pression
lorsque l'on rend elle dépend de nos
gaspillages anouk exacte et c'est pour
ça que s'il n'y a pas une contrainte est
bien plus engagés et efficient gaspille
plus gaie et plus et gagner et même plus
l'état gagné aussi
alors le voit très bien sur le pétrole
donc là il faut être vertueux et que
tout le monde soit gagnant gagnant donc
moi je trouve que c'est une très bonne
initiative
maintenant à ce que je regrette c'est la
commission européenne ils nous ont
proposé un texte qui est en droit d'en
parler juste après on a dans cette
émission l'habitude de 2,2
d'interviewer quelqu'un qui vous
interpelle vous mesdames les députés ont
l'écoutent c'est le monsieur qu'on a vu
dans le reportage on l'écouté vous
réagissez juste après
la commission a proposé un nouvel
objectif pour le paquet énergie climat à
l'horizon 2030 avec
finalement une réduction de 40% des
émissions de co2 comme objectif d'ici à
2030 par rapport à 1990 pour autant
l'efficacité énergétique n'apparaît pas
explicitement
est ce que vous pensez pas que c'est
pourtant probablement le thème au delà
du renouvelable dont on parle beaucoup
au delà des émissions de co2 avec
l'effet de serre mais dont on sait que
c'est très compliqué à mettre en oeuvre
parce qu'on avait les grandes
discussions internationales et qui le
consensus est dur tout est ce que vous
pensez pas que c'est le thème de
l'efficacité énergétique ou l'europe a
le plus de latitude
c'est le thème qui influencent le plus
la vie quotidienne de tout à chacun
et c'est finalement par ce type de
dispositif en étant volontariste qu'on
favorise la transition énergétique dont
tout le monde parle comme le futur
relais de croissance de création
d'emplois etc
voilà alors gaz à effet de serre
renouvelables on en parle toujours
l'efficacité énergétique on n'en parle
pas beaucoup alors quand on perd on est
en période de crise elle et ça parle au
citoyen lambda
sophie auconie c'est vraiment une chose
qui m'échappe je trouve que l'efficacité
énergétique finalement c'est ce qui est
le plus simple de mise en oeuvre
d'abord parce que c'est déjà accompagné
par l'union européenne à travers les
politiques régionales c'est à dire que
l'europe intervient auprès des citoyens
pour les aider à participer à
l'efficacité énergétique par l'isolation
de leur logement par exemple
donc ça veut dire que c'est quelque
chose qui est facile à mettre en oeuvre
l'efficacité énergétique et on l'a vu
tout à l'heure dans votre reportage et
alors là je ne comprends pas que ce soit
effectivement l'objectif qui était le
moins regardé deux mois soutenue par les
états et qui est un objectif ou un il
n'y a pas d'objectif en fait et je
trouve ça totalement surréalistes compte
tenu de la facilité de sujets rivasi
si vous voulez la ja ja on a un gros
souci avec la commission européenne
parce que ce qu'on avait mis dans le
package ainsi vous voulez ce plan climat
énergie 40% de réduction de 15% les gaz
à effet de serre d'ici à 2030 et âgées
assez alors ainsi 27 ans pour les
énergies renouvelables et ils ne parlent
pas d'efficacité énergétique
or ce qui est important c'est les trois
ensemble on peut pas réduire les gaz à
effet de serre si on ne réduit pas aussi
le comportement par rapport est
justement l'amélioration de l'efficacité
énergétique à la fois sur la technologie
est à la fois sur l'isolation et puis
maintenant il faut développer les
énergies renouvelables
sas avait été fait en 2008 or la
commission qu'elle ça il ya plus de
contraintes et chaque état n'est pas
obligé d'avancer compterait donc
heureusement là que le parlement a voté
une résolution pour dire mais on est en
désaccord total on parle de 2015 voyez
sur les accords internationaux
il faut absolument que l'europe soit
leader est là c'est parce que la france
et l'angleterre veulent développer le
nucléaire voyez pour dire on veut avoir
une europe décarbonés et en même temps
dans la pologne qui veut développer les
gaz de schiste et donc on veut
satisfaire tout le monde et on fait un
truc qui n'est pas contraignant alors
les parlementaires ont dit ça on n'est
pas d'accord il faut que ça soit bambi
c'est à dire que ce soit lié et on veut
une réduction à minima des 40%
nous les écologistes on demande 60% de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre il
faut que les énergies renouvelables
apporte l'indépendance et tout à l'heure
on parlait de l'ukraine
et vous voyez que cette indépendance est
très important qu'il faudra aller au
moins à minima à 35 % de l'énergie
renouvelable et puis il faut développer
l'efficacité énergétique a minima à 40%
sauf que cody la part du nucléaire le
gage de si je suppose que vous n'êtes
pas d'accord avec michèle rivasi je ne
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
michel ribes de votre voilà je considère
cher michel que effectivement au niveau
des gaz de schiste je ne suis pas pour
l'exploitation des gaz de schiste mais
je suis pour l'exploration parce que je
considère et d'un qu' il faut que avant
d'en discuter nous soyons nous sachions
ce qu'il ya dans nos sous sols et
ensuite je pense qu'il faut que nous
insistions à la recherche et à
l'innovation pour voir si les moyens de
d'exploitation sont adaptés à une vite
et d'avoir des impacts écologiques
majeurs oui mais écoute moi si on veut
réduire les gaz à effet de serre on peut
pas de l'autre côté développer les
énergies fossiles
il faut que l'on se soit de plus en plus
qu'on sort de l'addiction aux énergies
fossiles et les gaz de schiste on l'a
très bien vu
si on commence à faire de l'exploration
ça sera fait et on l'a vu en pologne
on le voit maintenant en angleterre avec
total ça se fait par les pétroliers donc
eux ils vont de toute façon nous cacher
l'information et puis il ya trop
d'opacité et trop de danger tu es
française comme moi comment on peut
calquer le modèle américain sur le
modèle français je suis d'accord avec
toi michel mais je te je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
crise conjoncturelle qu'il faut qu'on
regarde en face nos entreprises tombent
tous les jours nous avons eu plusieurs
milliers d'emplois si si c'est un vrai
sujet parce que la facture énergétique
est un des éléments qui fait que nos
entreprises perdent en compétitivité et
donc de façon très ponctuelle
en attendant que nous retrouvions
effectivement un moyen par l'efficacité
énergétique par les énergies
renouvelables de retrouver de la
compétitivité à travers l'énergie
nos entreprises en attendant il faut
qu'on regarde ça avec beaucoup d'autres
willis sophie excuse moi
la france est un des pays où
l'électricité la moins chère d'europe
donc ne me dis pas que c'est dû au prix
de l'électricité puisque c'est la moins
chère la compétitivité paliès les nos
industriels ils ont fait énormément
d'efforts sur l'efficacité énergétique
c'est pas les gaz de schiste qui vont
apporter dans la compétitivité on nous
mettra pas d'accord c'est là mesdames
c'est la fin de cette émission tout cas
on va pas on va parler de ce sujet lors
d'un sommet européen le 20 et 21 mars
prochains aulas n'avait pas d'accord il
faut les liens limiter ça va être
compliqué ça va être très très très
compliqué en tout cas on en parle dans
les jours à venir c'est la fin d'europe
hebdo merci de l'avoir suivi la semaine
prochaine vous retrouvez lenora hamadi à
cette même place d'ici là bonne suite
des programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires